the images of protesters lounging in the
pool cooking in the kitchen
and making themselves at home in the
presidential palace mark the
unforgettable and humiliating end to
gotabaya rajapaksa's short-lived tenure
as sri lankan president
elected in november 2019 he quickly
governed the country into a state of
destitution and desperation
by the time protesters forced him to
resign the nation had plummeted into an
economic crisis with no easy solutions
in sight
we have told the most powerful president
in the world to go home we have come
here braving tear gas water cannons and
bloodshed the protesters have already
released a list of demands they are not
requests these are the people's demands
it was a stunning reversal of fortunes
for rajapaksa and his powerful political
family
he was a third generation politician
his father was a member of parliament
and a cabinet minister his brother
served two terms as president
two other brothers also served in the
government
rajapaksa's supporters credited him with
helping to end a 26-year civil war
between the majority sinali's dominated
government and the minority tamil tigers
who wanted an independent state
an estimated 100 thousand people were
killed rajapaksa rose through the
military ranks and served during the
beginning of the war
then he emigrated to the united states
and worked as an i.t specialist and
manager of a convenience store
but in 2005 he returned to his homeland
to ensure his brother mahinda won a bid
to become president
rajapaksa became the defense minister
and his goal was to end the civil war
in 2006 he survived a suicide attack by
the tamil tigers
the u.n accused both sides of committing
war crimes
human rights groups accused rajapaksa of
disappearing opposition activists and
journalists and in 2015 interpol accused
him of engaging in corrupt practices to
obtain military hardware
he denied all the allegations
but what rajapaksa cannot deny is his
economic policies and allegations of
corruption led to dire shortages of food
fuel and medicine
whatever goodwill the island nation of
22 million once had for him and the
rajapaksa dynasty is now long gone
natasha name al jazeera